Je supplie que les gens puissent me dire leur nom d'
un goober jusqu'à votre portée à la un puissant
oh CLE modèle associé a yo giorgia
Horton Pluto banco para la copa cabana
Finn cnet wikinews OspA nuit Ellie go
Ellie Go key Luis Moreno
marant de l'ère communiste suis-je  comme une police de randonnée une grotte n'est
pas une piscine atusa réponse à la
synchronisation Polly Megara général donc
vous aviez une chance de changer la situation
prendriez-vous vous n'êtes pas efficace quand
vous avez volé vous ne bougez pas comme une
tortue rigamortis le monde
est diverti  par tant de gens de
l'arbre généalogique NWA, vous savez, de M&M à
snoop dogg à 50 cents à beats by dre
et puis vous avez des choses comme mes films
et toutes les personnes que j'ai diffusées, rien
de tout cela ne serait arrivé sans NWA
alors j'ai pensé  il était important de montrer à
la jeune génération d'où tout cela
vient vous pouvez le faire avec votre dos
dedans je peux le faire mettre votre acide dedans vous
pouvez le faire mettre votre poche bientôt je peux faire
un
pinceau c'est l'héritage de ma famille  et tu sais
t  siens, ils vont prendre ce film car la
loi a ce qui s'est passé, donc je devais
m'assurer que la trahison de mon père était à cent
pour cent authentique, car il se pourrait que j'ai
auditionné pour le rôle pendant plus de deux
ans avant de l'avoir, alors vous
savez quand  tu as mis autant de temps
et autant de travail ou quelque chose comme ça que ça va
la confiance en toi alors j'avais besoin pour
ce film, ils nous ont donné une chance alors de
bien faire aux États-Unis et maintenant
ils amènent son cul ici tu
sais pour  L'Europe est incroyablement ils veulent
NW blanc tuons-les en wa ce n'est
que la pointe de l'iceberg messieurs
que se passe-t-il qu'est-ce que vous avez dans ce
sac vous vous moquez de moi vous ne pouvez pas prendre
que
vous êtes l'un des premiers
publics français à  voyez ce chef-d'œuvre ce
film sur la façon dont nous nous sommes réunis et avons
changé le monde, donc nous apprécions vraiment que
vous veniez maintenant si vous
aimez le film tweetez à ce sujet instagram
quel que soit le tireur Graham qu'ils ont
sorti, vous allez le faire si vous ne le faites pas '  t aime le
mov  c'est-à-dire que vous vous tuez en sortant,
vous savez que ce ne sont pas les Crips et les
sangs c'est une menace du gouvernement fédéral
aucune génération ou alors y como
sashimi chanteuse OST moi Josh monstre
menifee Yamato de pasa Liz acteur la
musique las deux de esto  le personnage
memilih vraiment sympa si la façon de plans
sur toi pour toucher lachine salut soap
opera phenom salamo de lui typiquement pop
Oh CBRE LZ a développer insertion Dooku
sauvage Moyen Orient waffa waffa bonfim
dire fidelis Cujo saavedra moins tout un
parfait chabela me septa manana comédien
demandant une réponse du chef dong china jalapa vaca
casita broha a ramassé une
bête Remo
I